we understand that the billionaire Mike
Bloomberg the former mayor of New York
has pulled out of the race following a
disappointing night on Super Tuesday so
he has pulled out of that race and he is
now we understand endorsing Joe Biden
former Vice President Joe Biden winning
at least nine states from 14 on Super
Tuesday a really strong showing against
his main rival Bernie Sanders who we
understand is on course to pick up
California which has the largest number
of Delegates in that round of Super
Tuesday but Michael Bloomberg pulling
out of that race Donald Trump mocked him
on Twitter after Super Tuesday he said
the biggest loser tonight by far is Mini
Mike Bloomberg his political consultants
took him for a ride 700 million dollars
washed down the drain and he got nothing
for it but that nickname and a complete
destruction of his reputation way to go
Mike so Mike Bloomberg may be taking
that to heart and of course the result
of Super Tuesday but he is out that ends
his race
you